hi oh hi nitrosyl agreed that no now you
know your life is different now I'm
vlogging today and I'm vlogging in
Orlando Florida I'm here to go to
Wrestlemania yeah with my friend mamrie
Hart my friend Jared sleeper we're super
excited shave the day we got into our
little fire yesterday we got in it like
11:00 and we were hungry I want to drink
and we found a bar on Google Maps and we
got there we realized we were in like
the center of downtown with tons of bars
and restaurants and so we um we tied
went on it wasn't even the main event so
now it's 2:00 p.m. on Sunday and I'm in
my hotel room Jarett memory went to
rainforest cafe I could not handle that
today I'm trying to recuperate before we
have to go in a couple hours to
Wrestlemania I'm hanging out with some
good friends this is a great angle I'm
great at blogging hang out with some
good buddies oh this is slowest most
anti-climatic resume of all time so
that's the update now let's take you and
myself to Wrestlemania let's get ready
happening we're going we're going to get
there okay humidity's here well if it
doesn't make any sense
yeah let's do this okay we just got here
you can see I don't know if you can see
them all these trucks with all the
wrestlers on them this is the beautiful
glamorous behind the scenes they're all
really amped we're going to buy merch
immediately please remember it as we are
now because if I slid to Yelp
everything's about to change all year
surrounded by like gargantuan men for
seconds we're healthy is here my things
I can't learn more otherwise we're under
the brand under the brand that they
entered yes oh my gosh oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god
is unreal what is happening I went to
college to be able to be here right now
albeit obtained under four classes the
OTD the real smell hasn't even like
really started it's still a breeze
always like Marvin is like what comes
the child becomes a child I made a cameo
[Music]
this love for Alexis
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I
it's a glass
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ha
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
time to go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is definitely WrestleMania people
come here that's up there Oh God a
bloated drowned rat but look she's
serving the morning after WrestleMania I
feel like I lost 30 years of my life
no thank you it was honestly so
incredible and I want to go every year
we are going to check out of our hotel
it's like 12:30 almost 1:00 Lu blackout
curtains no I kept thinking was 7 a.m.
10:00 that was noon we're going to now I
head to the airport in a little bit
after I clean myself up but before that
we're going to ship our chairs at a
FedEx station back to Los Angeles I just
re-watched my Instagram story there's
still rewards if anyone finds my mind
that I lost last night okay let's get on
the plane to go to Amsterdam now to do
VidCon and Amsterdam
this is my favorite favorite dream got
much together slightly memory night
turns out love wearing identical
unplanned outfit we are now currently
headed a FedEx so we can ship our
Wrestlemania chairs to ourselves in Los
Angeles because this day bays are to fit
to leave here we lost many a thing in
many a hotel room but none see hi
great solving here you might remember me
from the previous six to seven minutes
of this vlog I'm in Amsterdam right now
and I realize it didn't end out this
video so here's me ending this video
thank you for watching me lose them on
at WrestleMania I hope that you enjoyed
it if you guys want me to vlog like this
more often like I used to do a little
bit more let me know in the comments
down below give this video thumbs up to
if you like vlogging videos for
wrestling or me or anything that you'd
like if you liked it like this video
other than that subscribe to this
youtube channel and i don't know
honestly WrestleMania because that's a
normal sentence that you say on a wire a
turd a very open just accidentally I
said I was okay thank you
flag flag flag restricted mode
restricted